give us the money yo I don't like your
tone excuse me
you being disrespectful it's not
necessary hmm yo Amos what uh showed a
man with two things
[Music]
you want something
hey youtubers this charlie get rekt this
is gonna be so much fun so luke age
dropping September thirtieth let's break
this down there's also an Iron Fist
teaser that I'll talk about at the end
of this Luke Cage stuff first this is
from the first episode it's really just
meant to show you what he can do just
like the other gangsters that are
holding up that restaurant say show them
what you do till he gets rekt trying to
wreck Luke Cage in the really nice touch
here that I appreciate they don't need
to do this but it just adds that
something extra makes it that much more
realistic they have the Gunpowder on the
inside of Luke cages hand where the
bullet discharged that's actually what
happens when the boat leaves the chamber
you also see that reaction on his face
like he feels it it doesn't really hurt
him but just because his skin isn't
vulnerable doesn't mean that he doesn't
feel things like when he's having sex
with Jessica Jones he definitely feels
that sweet Christmas he felt that so
like anytime somebody throws him through
a window or he bashes through something
he still feels it but you know like
Wolverine they just get used to it even
though your body's still feeling the
same amount of pain but these dudes are
just part of his call to action and like
in the first episode as things pick up
he's trying to hide out at the end of
Jessica Jones he took off things were
getting really hot he didn't want to
land on the police's radar and kilgrave
had led this wake of destruction just
leading to Luke Cage he's like alright
peace I'm out I'm going up to Harlem I'm
gonna hide out for a little while and
that's where we find him with pops in
the trailer pops I'm thinking of is like
his version of stick like the wise old
man that explains things for him in
terms that he can understand like look
this is what's happening to Harlem maybe
you should help out then you have people
like misty night who come along and like
look dude you seriously need to get off
your ass and do something about this
neighborhood so then he sees stuff like
this and this is like the real call to
action like people are being threatened
at gunpoint so I'm gonna throw it out
like this is enough
so like by the end of the series he'll
be Luke Cage Hero for Hire that most of
you guys are familiar with either in the
comics so the animated series but here's
the really cool thing they've released
the titles of all 13 episodes and
they're all gang star songs if you don't
know who they are they're just a big
hip-hop group that's important to the
East Coast scene they were also
associated with wu-tang the showrunner
said that Luke Cage as a series is kind
of like the wu-tang of
occasion of the Marvel Universe so of
course all the episode titles are going
to be the titles of hip-hop songs it's
just that all the songs are taken from
the same hip-hop duo so the first
episode is called moment of truth go to
the streets who's gonna take the weight
step in the arena just to get a rep suck
as me body God's manifest blowing up the
spot D Wyck take it personal now you're
mine soliloquy of chaos and then you
know my steez so for some of you this
will actually mean something way deeper
but if you're not a super big hip-hop
fan then you will be by the end of this
series just listen to a lot of ODB
that'd be good prep for this you should
also listen to each of these Gang Starr
songs but these will appear throughout
the certain like they actually use these
songs in those episodes so thematically
culturally all very important to what's
going on with this series in the Marvel
Universe contextualizing the Luke Cage
character and the history of Harlem and
East Coast hip-hop just a really good
meta example of how important music is
to all these Netflix series in how
creatively there's just a step above
most other big cable shows so get rekt
it's all dropping September 30th I'll be
posting my episode 1 video that night
like later that night and then the rest
of the videos will post over the next
couple days so in related news the iron
fist teaser we'll probably see a whole
bunch of iron fist at the end of Luke
Cage but the teaser that Finn Jones
dropped iron fist himself is for the
person who is responsible for training
people that come to the mystic city
where iron fist gets his powers so the
message itself and you can actually just
pause the video here if you want to read
it yourself
explaining his thesis explaining what
he's getting ready to undertake and the
meaning of it all so it's kind of like
him saying this is what's going to
happen this is what's expected of you
and this is your reward if you're able
to do this you will be invited to eat
the fruit of immortality and then you
will truly be among us so just sounds
very ominous like oh my god I can't wait
to see this obviously it's not gonna
drop till early next year so it's gonna
be a while but we'll get all kinds of
teasers once Luke age drops remember the
first Luke Cage teaser was attached to
the very last episode of daredevil
season 2 so it's gonna be the same thing
with iron fist they'll drop a new
iron fist teaser with that last episode
of Luke Cage on Netflix so get hype and
there is a new round of the marvel
giveaway that's going on right now it's
the Captain America Civil War blu-ray
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
what I'm gonna do next is I'll probably
post some Thor Ragnarok later tonight
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for Scarlet Witch and
vision teaser and you can click here to
learn all about sabotage backstory and
the flash season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight